well remember when shaq played a
superhero kevin
in steel well he's got a new challenge
now but first jack and i talked about
something serious tiger woods car crash
because for shaq
it brought back the painful memories of
losing kobe
i came around and hit the living room i
saw the car first
and it was beat up nobody was in it and
then i saw a tiger
involved and i didn't want to finish
reading it
because when i got the news about my
friend
kobe just passed away it was shocking
when i saw the picture of tyler's cars
like
please not not not this but i'm glad
he's okay
i wish him well
as tiger continues his road to recovery
shaq is on a path of his own to the
wrestling ring
he'll be taking on pro wrestler cody
rhodes tomorrow night on tnt's aew
dynamite
i hear there's some some rumors that
he's going to buy this game first of
[Music]
it's shocking that he would think i am
too little everyone
is too little for shaq i think he's
going up i really do i think i can get
him up
this isn't shaq's first dangerous
face-off remember when he swam with
sharks
twice
and saturday he's got a birthday to
celebrate you're gonna turn the big four
nine
what are you gonna do i want you to come
to the set with flowers
and a big 34 carat diamond ring
you